have you ever wondered what the  eccentric dangerous dr bride wants more  than anything in the world foundation  researchers used scp-978 the desire  camera to snap a photo of dr bryant  while he was having a heated argument  with dr cleff dr cleff was not caught on  camera and only dr bright was captured  in the photograph this was the result  entire scene has changed appears to be  outside sky and background grass and  foreground subject of picture is simple  tombstone bearing the engraving jack  bright resting at last a surprisingly  somber wish from a figure that has  brought so much chaos to those around  him maybe one day he will finally find  his peace